hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
welcome to this quick review of the
Google Play edition HTC One m8 now I
always say welcome to this quick video
and then ends up being like 9 minutes
long so I think this can actually be a
quick video review because I've already
reviewed at the regular HTC One m8 I'll
have that link as the first link right
below that like button if you want to
check out all the details of that phone
in full so I guess what we can focus on
now here is the differences between the
Google Play edition and the non Google
Play edition One m8 let's take a look so
on the outside this Google Play edition
is the exact same as the other version
it's got that same legendary all-metal
design same awesome specs and it's still
built like a boss so no changes there
the only difference is actually the lack
of any carrier branding at all on the
Google Play edition where you'll likely
find some sort of [ __ ] stamp on all the
carrier versions here you can see
Verizon being the most guilty as usual
so that means all the differences lie in
the software to where the Google Play
edition One m8 is running stock Android
4.4.2 kitkat and will likely be upgraded
to the next version of Android before
the regular m8 and likely right behind
the Nexus updates so with this software
that means they're getting essentially
the same experience as if you're using a
Nexus device but wait what about all the
HTC features that could potentially make
it better than a nexus only experience
well no need to fear your HTC put a
bunch of their apps and services here in
the Play Store and that's where they can
update them and they've made them
compatible with the Google Play edition
One m8 so even though you tap into it
and it says it's not compatible they are
installed here and are working perfectly
so this phone will work with the dot
view case that got so much attention
it'll work with the IR blaster and the
top of the phone to control your TV with
that app and most importantly the Google
Play edition One m8 also takes advantage
of that duo camera system on the back we
talked a lot about this in the regular
one and make review but obviously the
Google Play edition does not have that
same camera app it's rocking that new
Google camera app in the Play Store for
all devices running Android 4.4 KitKat
and above that means it has a different
user interface which is not HTC specific
so
you use the fun stuff like you focus and
foreground ER and stuff well basically
you take a picture as usual here and
then when you swipe over and hit the
edit button on that photo you'll have an
option to pop up you can do it using the
regular google photos editor or the HTC
photo editor and it's by jumping in here
that you can use that beautiful you
focus and foreground ER and all the same
effects that you used to with the
regular m8 s-- camera that's where it
hides so there's actually a really neat
little effect now built into the google
camera it's called lens blur which is
not exactly the same thing but really it
lets you get a similar blurred
background effect by tilting the phone a
bit obviously you focus is a bit easier
because you don't have to move the phone
while taking the shot but now you have I
guess two options on the phone for
blurring the background only thing that
seems to not be working in the camera is
the slow-motion video recording and the
little warning that's supposed to pop up
if you accidentally cover the depth
sensor which actually did a lot maybe I
have big hands and that's why but I
guess I'm gonna have to adjust the way I
grip the phone when taking pictures with
it now another thing you might recall
from the One m8 review is the ability to
turn your phone on without touching this
power button with just a double tap or a
swipe across the screen these options
are present in the settings here they
are called motion launch gestures and
there's even it's actually simplified
here really you can just double tap to
wake or sleep the screen on the lock
screen you can do the volume button turn
to launch the camera or swipe literally
in any direction on the off screen to
unlock your phone so it doesn't really
matter which direction you swipe it's
not going to launch any special HTC
voice tiling or anything any swipe in
any direction just unlocks the phone but
other than that this is you know exactly
what you would expect out of the m8 with
stock Android on it you know simple
clean very fast you use a little bit
less of the built-in storage but you
also keep that microSD card expansion
that you actually don't get in nexuses
you also use a little bit less of the
RAM than you would from HTC Sense and
you get an overall really snappy buttery
beautiful experience so you have all the
perks and good looks from stock Android
that I actually prefer over really any
skin including HTC Sense 6 so that's
really why I've loved using it so much
obviously Google Play edition stuff is
from the Google Play Store only and
a US only store and also it's out of
inventory right now as I speak but when
it is in inventory it's only available
in the 32 gig Silver Edition so no dark
charcoal or gold or any of the fancy
colors just this exact model is the only
one you can get and it's only in the
United States because see Google Play
Store it's also not available on Verizon
in case you were thinking of putting a
Verizon same in it it won't work
it's GSM only so I have my AT&T SIM in
here basically bottom line is this is
the phone that I mentioned that I would
probably be using most often I put I
said on Twitter a couple of days ago
this is the phone I think I'm going to
have my SIM card in the most often when
I'm not reviewing another device what
you guys would refer to as a daily
driver so I think this Google Play
edition one is the one might either way
thank you for watching this quick video
review hopefully gets the point across
and I'm looking forward to reviewing
some other phones very soon and as well
as getting back to other stuff that's
not phone reviews because it's been a
while since I've done a video that's not
a phone review so thanks for watching
and talk to you guys in the next one
peace